Oh hello i know right
Welcome back everyone it's Charlie this is
going to be my new deadpool 3 movie video
marvel and ryan reynolds just did this big super
post explaining what's going on with the future of
the franchise under marvel studios so grab your
chimichangas we'll break it all down if you're
brand new to the channel be sure to subscribe to
get all the videos we'll do a new amazon giveaway
all you have to do to enter is be a subscriber and
let me know which other mcu movies you want to see
deadpool cross over into during marvel phase
4 marvel phase 5. but big stuff first grab
your chimichangas this past week marvel and
rhine rentals announced that they were finally
finally moving forward on deadpool 3 under the
marvel studios banner it's about time they gave
us an update they've been talking about the movie
all year long ryan reynolds has been going on talk
shows since last christmas like he did his ugly
sweater interviews where he was telling people
yeah we're definitely working on the movie right
now that fell apart quickly this is just you and
me logan i guess so you know uh you know what that
makes this a reunion for x-men origins reunite
yeah you listen to that now and you're like well
wait a minute if they're just talking about it
now what was happening this whole time what
was going on behind the scenes we saw him go
meet with marvel he even posted these funny
jokes about trying to audition for tony stark
so during this past week in the big announcement
they talked about some of the big changes that
have happened to the movie since ryan reynolds
was talking about this earlier since the fox
disney buyout started there have been a couple
different versions of deadpool 3 that they've
been working on so behind the scenes things have
actually changed quite a bit since the beginning
but now we have an idea for where the movie
is going to fall during the marvel phase 4
marvel phase 5 release schedule so i'll explain
that too in a lot of the avengers crossover
questions like how is deadpool going to be brought
into the mcu will he be rated r thankfully they
answered all those questions so first things first
deadpool 3 is confirmed to be rated r at least the
theatrical cut the one that we'll go see in movie
theaters i'm sure they'll ponder doing a once
upon a deadpool version of the movie later after
the rated r cut hits theaters because they want
as much content on disney plus as possible and
there's a reason why you don't see the deadpool
movies on disney plus right now because they're
rated r there been rumors that they're gonna roll
out a special adult section of disney plus at some
point in the future that's password locked like
if you remember old cable boxes having special
passwords that your parents had to put on them
but if you remember once upon a deadpool when
they were doing the trailers for that they
started taking shots at disney they made a whole
big joke of it because they were making deadpool 2
while the fox disney buyout deal had started so
they knew that it was going to happen eventually
owner rent spoon why the mask ugly why the jokes
insecure why princess bride i'm a fan why celine
dion i'm a bigger fan by the holidays thought
it'd be fun rpg 13. it's a family movie also money
also disney taking all the shots at disney that's
like the easiest thing that they could possibly do
there were some disney jokes though ryan reynolds
said that fox people made them take out of that
and the screenwriters i'll explain that in a
second because normally you would expect they
let ryan reynolds do whatever he wants with the
deadpool movies because they're so much cheaper to
make than traditional big mcu movies so it's not
quite as big of a financial risk but the first big
change with deadpool 3 they just announced though
is they have new screenwriters working on another
new script with ryan reynolds if you guys didn't
know ryan reynolds actually produced the first
deadpool movie he didn't just act in it but he
also got a screenwriting credit when it came to
deadpool 2. meaning that he helped write the story
for that the same is going to be true for deadpool
3 when he was talking about the movie earlier
this year like yeah we're working on deadpool 3
right now he was talking about writing their early
pitches for deadpool 3 with kevin feige and marvel
in the original writers of the movies i write it
with two other guys rhett reese and paul wernick
who are geniuses and amazing in you know in so
many ways and and we just have so much fun we
actually ride it all right in here in this room um
where i'm sitting and um and we just have the best
time doing it together so we hope that we're gonna
there's a lot more to a lot more story to tell so
we hope we get to do that there's a couple jokes
that you told me about i won't say now because i
don't want to ruin if it's in the third one but it
didn't make it to the second one but it was really
really funny thing that was going on i
was like oh don't never let you do that
yeah you could fill a gymnasium with some of the
jokes that got cut out of deadpool one and two
that would get us all arrested or turned into some
sort of disney liquid he has way more power at the
studio now just because the deadpool movies have
been so successful so marvel really wanted to lock
him down for long term it's the same thing
with robert downey jr in the iron man movies
they blew up big time he got paid big time and
had a lot of say in the future of his character
recently this past year when ryan reynolds met
with kevin foggy after the big fox x-men fantastic
four buyout was done part of them signing him to a
new contract reportedly involved a bunch of extra
cameos in addition to the traditional films in the
crossover mcu films that they want him for when we
all heard that everyone just kind of assumed that
he would be like the new stan lee type character
just popping up in funny post-credit scenes or
funny one-off cameos or just really silly things
in the backgrounds of movies when he's not an
actual main character that kind of meta humor
is just baked into the deadpool character so it
would make sense they would use him for something
like that but when i talk about the mcu crossover
movies i'm talking about avengers 5 or the other
bigger movies that they would put him in as
a main character they haven't said anything
about deadpool 4 but if they're doing four thor
movies i think it just depends on how long ryan
reynolds wants to do deadpool movies it sounds
like he wants to keep doing them for as long
as marvel will have him but one of the biggest
changes they just announced this week is that
they actually brought on new screenwriters that's
a pair from the bob's burgers tv show that's why
all the deadpool social media accounts posted this
picture of bob from bob's burgers with deadpool's
katanas i think a lot of people were confused
by that like what is bob gonna be in deadpool
3 i don't understand what's this now i am kind
of wondering though if h jon benjamin is going
gonna have a cameo in deadpool 3. he's the voice
of bob he also does archer and a bunch of other
stuff he has a very identifiable voice there's
also the very famous hydra bob in the deadpool
comics but they already did that character during
the first deadpool movie they just didn't do the
hydra part because at the time fox and marvel
still had the whole rights issue but fun fact
if you re-watch that first deadpool movie and you
look at the final battle in the scrap yard there
that actually took place on one of nick fury's
shield hella carriers which was just their way
of making fun of marvel referencing the avengers
movie but the even bigger news that most people
haven't really registered yet though is it part of
the announcement they said that marvel studios is
going to release a rated r deadpool movie which
no one thought that they would do ever because
it's disney and anytime disney has released rated
r movies in the past they usually do it under a
different studio banner like touchstone so people
just assumed when they said that deadpool 3 would
be rated r that they would do the same thing for
that and they wouldn't release it with the marvel
studios banner but apparently they're doing
it here's the thing though deadpool in the mcu
the mcu is firmly pg-13 meaning that even though
marvel studios is doing a rated r movie deadpool
3 will probably mostly be self-contained you won't
see a ton of mainstream avengers characters show
up like spider-man captain america the hulk you
get the idea they'll just do whatever they want to
do it'll be this self-contained little bubble of
continuity and you just hear deadpool taking a ton
of shots at disney avengers endgame jokes making
fun of iron man the infinity gauntlet jokes about
him dying remember him making fun of hugh jackman
at the beginning of deadpool 2 for dying in the
logan movie imagine him doing the same thing for
robert downey jr in tony stark when it comes to
proper mcu movie crossover though because they
also confirmed deadpool would cross over with the
avengers eventually they'll probably save a moment
like that for the deadpool 3 post-credits scene or
one of the post-credits scenes something really
easy to do but explainable him actually showing
up in some clearly identifiable mcu location like
spider-man's bedroom or showing up at the avengers
tower in midtown only to find that they've already
moved out or even showing up in the sanctum think
about it this way too doctor strange 2 is probably
the best way to explain how marvel can reference
all the fox x-men movies and keep deadpool around
long term while also doing brand new rebooted
versions of the x-men characters in fantastic four
in the mcu like how do we keep some of this stuff
from the fox x-men movies but not everything and
the answer to that is the multiverse it's the big
arc of marvel phase four starting in wandavision
things get crazy in the title of doctor strange 2
is literally multiverse of madness but because
they just hired the deadpool 3 writers officially
the timeline usually goes like this by comic
con next year they'll probably announce who
the new director is going to be and they'll
start filming the movie at least by early 2022
then release deadpool 3 in theaters during 2023.
they could release it a little bit before then
like at the end of 2022 it just depends on
when they actually start filming the movie
but either way it still comes well after doctor
strange 2 so there's plenty of time for him to
fall through one of dr strange's portals in a
deadpool 3 post credit scene and then cameo in
a couple other marvel phase 4 marvel phase 5
movies or they can even do the weird captain
america non-diegetic post-credit scene like the
spider-man homecoming post-credits scene where
he just shows up out of nowhere to lecture
the audience on patience and then walks off
then just in terms of other future mcu crossover
movies i think we all expect deadpool to show up
in the future x-men movies once marvel gets around
to making those and then of course avengers 5. but
the next really big marvel thing that's happening
is obviously the Wandavision episodes those are
going to start january 15th i'll be doing videos
for all those episodes and that's really when
the big marvel phase 4 stuff is going to start
spinning up everyone click here for all the new
black panther 2 movie announcements they just made
this week and click here for my full mandalorian
season 2 episode 4 video thank you so much for
watching everyone stay safe maximum effort!